[Music]
good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to speak today my name is
jennifer davis and my discussion will
focus on a recently developed method for
the separation of four thc isomers using
liquid chromatography mass spectrometry
first a little bit of background about
the hemp farming act of 2018. in 2014
the farm bill distinguished hemp from
marijuana but the interpretation of this
law was vague and difficult
it was not until the hemp farming act
was signed into law in december 2018
that the legalization of the cultivation
and distribution of hemp was federally
legalized
now how did this affect the controlled
substance act and the implications on
cannabis and law enforcement
well marijuana is still considered a
scheduled one drug however it removes
the plant cannabis sativa from the csa
as long as the plant contains no more
than 0.3 percent thc by dry weight
this is very important as this was the
first time a value was placed upon the
psychoactive compound which forced
forensics and seized drug laboratories
to adapt methodology
when the farm bill in 2018 was initially
released there were headlines all over
the u.s looking to determine how to
interpret this law how do you tell the
two apart since they're from the same
plant and how do you know when to
prosecute
even more recently with the decline in
cbd sales many hemp growers and sellers
began to move to other variants of thc
delta 8 for example is derived from cbd
and increased in popularity because it
is not specified as a part of the farm
bill and therefore is not considered
illegal so now not only was an adapted
methodology needed for quantitation but
ideally there should be separation of
the different thc variants
traditionally qualitative analysis is
done using either a gcfid or gcms
instrument however there are limitations
to using a gc
because of the heated injection port all
acid forms of thc are converted to delta
9 thc due to heat
this conversion is not always 100
so one would need to report the total
thc content as opposed to each
individual thc isomer
you could also perform derivatization of
the thca
but this can be a tedious process
due to these limitations other
analytical techniques should be explored
an alternate analytical technique that
could offer accurate quantitation of
each cannabinoid and thc present
including the acid form could be liquid
chromatography or liquid chromatography
mass spectrometry lc allows for full
separation of all native and acid forms
of the thc isomers as well as providing
spectral information if a mass spec is
used for additional detection for the
remainder of the talk i will be
discussing the use of an lcms method for
quantitation and separation of four
delta thc isomers
these methods will include an inline pda
for additional detection as well as
comparing both a single quadrupole and
triple quadruple
since the farm bill is left to
interpretation for what value of thc is
required many states have implemented
their own interpretation of the bill
delta 9 is known to have the psychedelic
effects but there's nothing in the bill
about other delta analogs here we show
the structures of each of the analogs as
you can see they only differ where the
double bond is located in the six
membered ring in addition delta 10 and
delta 6a10a have a chiral center
typically one would need to have a
chiral column to fully separate out the
different chiral compounds but for
purposes of just differentiating each
isomer a method using reverse phase
chromatography and common lcms solvents
was sufficient in our method both the r
and s variations for delta 10 and delta
6a10a allude as one peak
for the first analytical technique we
will evaluate using lcpda with the
addition of a single quad mass spec as
with gcms the addition of a mass spec
allows for confirmation of the isomers
by providing specific mass spec
information plus the ability to use an
internal standard for quantitation the
mass spec also provides the ability to
run fast scans in both positive and
negative polarities simultaneously
allowing for a single lc injection
for the single quad method all standards
were purchased from cayman chemical in
addition to the chiral isomers a four
component mix was run which included cbd
thca delta 8 and delta 9 thc
chromatographic separation was achieved
using an eight-minute method in a five
microliter injection volume
mobile phase a consisted of five
millimolar ammonium formate with 0.1
percent formic acid and mobile phase b
consisted of a mix of methanol and
acetonitrile with 0.1 percent formic
acid
the final gradient conditions and method
parameters can be seen in the tables
displayed
here we are demonstrating the separation
of each isomer using lcpda and a single
quad
the top chromatogram is from the pda at
220 nanometers the bottom chromatogram
is from the single quad
the black trace is for a sim event
monitoring a mass to charge of 315 in
positive mode and the pink trace is for
a sim event monitoring mass to charge
357 in negative mode
not shown here is the sim event that
monitored mass to charge 317 in positive
mode used for the internal standard
if we look even closer at the
chromatograms generated from the single
quad we can see distinct baseline
separation between delta 8 and delta 9
thc
as well as sufficient resolution between
delta 10
and 6a 10a
one of the benefits to using the mass
spec is that we can perform in source
fragmentation
in order to induce fragmentation of each
of these isomers for secondary
conformation
one can see when comparing the spectrum
for delta 8 and delta 9 they are very
similar they have multiple fragments in
common including mass to charge 247.
when we perform the in-source
fragmentation by applying a dc voltage
to our q array one can see that there is
a 239 mass to charge peak that is unique
to delta 8 specifically this can assist
with further differentiating each
analyte as well as providing more
confidence in the results
in addition to that both delta 10 and
delta 6 a10a show unique masses when
in-source fragmentation is performed
in this particular example you can see
that delta 10 has a specific mass to
charge of 217 whereas delta 6a10a has a
fragment seen at 299.
both are specific to these isomers only
all calibration curves were run in
triplicate and had at least five points
with a correlation coefficient of
0.996 or better
internal standard quantitation was used
with a 1 over c weighting for all
analytes a deuterated form of delta 9
thc was used as the internal standard
and was spiked using 25 microliters at a
500 nanogram per microliter
concentration for all samples
the accuracy of each calibrator was
between 83.7 percent and
117.3 percent with a percent rsd of 7.85
or better
meat calibration curves were run from
0.01 nanograms per microliter to 10
nanograms per microliter the exact
calibration range varying for each
analyte
the average accuracy for all calibrators
is shown here in addition to running
this method in meat standards we tested
a matrix matched calibration curve but
found interference was seen from the
presence of native cannabinoids in the
matrix
two hemp samples were extracted and
analyzed against the calibration curves
sample extraction was completed using
100 milligrams of dry flour geogrinded
for five minutes at 1000 rpm
10 milliliters of methanol was then
added and the sample was vortexed for
one minute before centrifuging
one milliliter of the supernatant was
then aliquoted into a sample vial for
injection
all calibrators and hemp samples were
spiked with the deuterated delta 9 thc
for internal standard quantitation
as you can see here
the spiked hemp sample clearly still
demonstrates baseline separation of
delta 8 and delta 9 as well as
sufficient resolution between delta 10
and delta 6 a10a
three equations were used to determine
the total amount of thc in each of the
hemp flower samples equation 3 was used
to determine the percent thc for each
individual isomer within the samples
equation 1 is the most common
calculation used based on the
specifications of the hemp farm act
it uses only delta 9 thc when
determining the total thc content
whereas equation 2 takes into
consideration all thc isomers when
calculating the final thc content
the second analytical technique we will
discuss uses an lc pda with the addition
of a triple quad mass spec the triple
quad still has all of the added benefits
a mass spec has to offer such as the use
of an internal standard or a single lc
injection to run both positive and
negative polarities
in addition to this the triple quad
offers higher selectivity and
specificity because of the
collision-induced fragmentation
this allows us to use smaller injection
volumes while still achieving lower
detection limits than what was observed
with both the single quad or pda
the smaller injection volume also helps
reduce the frequency of cleaning needed
and any potential matrix interference
that could be seen
for the triple quad method all standards
were purchased from cayman chemical in
addition to the chiral isomers a 10
component mix and eight additional
standards were run these consisted of a
variety of cannabinoids including the
more common ones such as cbd thca and
cbc
as well as additional emerging
cannabinoids such as cbt cbco and delta
9 thcp
the same chromatographic method in lcms
solvents were used the major difference
to the method being the 1 microliter
injection volume needed instead of the 5
microliter injection volume used on the
single quad
just like with the single quad being
sure we can individually identify and
quantify each isomer as well as the
other cannabinoids present in our
samples is needed
the top chromatogram is from the pda at
220 nanometers the bottom chromatogram
is from the triple quad
multiple mrn traces can be seen for each
cannabinoid each analyte consists of at
least one quantifier transition as well
as two to four qualifier transitions
as you can see the triple quad achieved
complete separation and identification
for all 20 cannabinoids and thc isomers
present
but the pda did not the three
highlighted areas demonstrate where two
analytes could be identified using
analyte specific mrm transitions without
requiring complete baseline separation
in our first example we can see that cbg
and cbd coalute in our pda chromatogram
they still elute at the same time for
the triple quad chromatogram but the
ability to use different mrm transitions
specific to each analyte means
individual quantitation can still be
completed
in the second example we can see the
addition of the internal standard
the triple quad mass spec again allows
us to individually identify the
deuterated form of delta 9 thc
from the native delta 9 thc
whereas in the pda chromatogram no
presence of the internal standard can be
seen
our last example again shows two peaks
alluding at the same time and the mass
spec being required to properly identify
and quantify these analytes without
needing baseline resolution
in addition to this though it shows the
ability of the mass effect to identify
and quantify two analytes and opposing
polarities with no compromise and still
utilizing the one injection
two hemp samples were extracted and
analyzed against the triple quad method
the same sample extraction used for the
single quad was completed for the triple
quad starting with 100 milligrams of dry
flour and ending with a one milliliter
of supernatant
due to the added sensitivity and
calibration range used on the triple
quad though
additional dilutions were needed for the
final hemp sample injections
as you can see here the sample still
demonstrates baseline separation and
sufficient resolution for all four
isomers as well as the identification of
the additional cannabinoids present in
the sample
throughout this discussion we
demonstrated the development of a method
that shows separation of four thc
isomers that method was then applied to
both a single quad and triple quad
we completed the quantitation of each
analyte using high accuracy and percent
rsds
and we accurately measured each thc
isomer within a hemp sample
currently final quantitation of all 20
cannabinoids and the more comprehensive
method is being completed
i would like to thank rachel lieberman
and eberhart kuhnen for more information
go to www.growyourlab.com
or feel free to email me at jcdavis
shamatsu.com
you